is Paul Charles light of a professor at
New York University's Wagner school of
public service
one of my main recommendations is that
you know let's flatten the hierarchy
let's get rid of about a half of the
political appointees at the top of
government you know the Obama
administration and previous
administrations have argued that they
need every last political appointee it's
only a small number come on I mean in
the grand scheme of things you've got
3,000 appointees out of 1.8 million
full-time civil servants what's the big
deal well the big deal is that those
3,000 political appointees occupy
between a quarter and two fifths of all
the layers that get in the way of
accountability so I've been recommending
you know a reduction in political
appointees a reduction in management
layers bulking up of the oversight
mechanisms that we have in government
like the offices of Inspector General
which are responsible for audits and
investigation strengthening the
acquisitions workforce that oversees
contractors you know really trying to
revitalize and flatten this gigantic
hierarchy that is so difficult to manage
well you know I thought a lot about the
notion of using AmeriCorps as a jobs
program of a sort that's not how
AmeriCorps members view their jobs but
you know if we increase the number of
AmeriCorps volunteers from 75,000 which
is the current allotment to let's say a
million you'd have an instant Works
Progress Administration put a lot of
people to work in the nonprofit sector
which is suffering mightily everybody
wants a bailout right now but nobody
talks about the nonprofit sector and
it's terrible credit crunch I mean
nonprofits are really suffering in this
country so I mean I'm not exactly sure
that the Works Progress Administration
is the right model but we do need to use
our resources wisely you know to
accomplish multiple goals expanding
AmeriCorps would allow us to employ a
million Americans in doing good work to
help the nonprofit sector survive the
current crisis and I kind of like that
idea as part of economic stimulus as
well as part of Obama's commitment to an
expanded public service
Obama could engage in online dialogue
with young Americans and and actually
Americans of any age and persuasion to
sort of try to understand what it is
that comes first for him that would be
an aggressive way of engaging the public
every president since Jack Kennedy has
had a White House bolster so the White
House has always been looking out to see
how the public reacts to what the White
House wants to do well what about
letting the public look in and
participate in agenda-setting idealism
by itself is not enough its idealism
harnessed to disruptive change that I
think young Americans want and and older
Americans want as well it is not a
idealism that just kind of exists in the
ether it's an idealism that is married
to tangible goals